don't we all love to watch our favorite
movie
on a big screen with a tub full of
popcorn
yes we do but have you ever noticed
how you get from a point where you
decide which movie you want to watch
to a point where you actually watch it
in the theater
there are so many levels checking out
the movie review
finding a multiplex that is running your
favorite film
checking the show timings and
availability of the seats
and finally booking your tickets phew
but today all this can be done with just
a few clicks
thanks to book my show all you need to
do
is connect to the internet download book
my show app
and woohoo there you have your e-ticket
the next thing you'll be doing is
sitting on a cozy comfy reclining chair
and watching your favorite movie
well let's see from where it all started
and how an idea
evolved into a huge success
[Music]
now for a moment imagine that you don't
have the internet
and there's no way to access book my
show how do you think you would book
your tickets
or how will you know which multiplex is
showing your favorite movie
or for that matter the show timings the
reviews and the ratings
scary isn't it well
that's how the world was 20 years ago
when there was no internet
no real-time connectivity and of course
no
book my show so how did people manage to
book tickets back then
seems impossible to imagine right this
is what they would do
firstly they would check the newspaper
ads to find out
which movie was running in which theater
and at what time
then they would go to the movie theater
well in advance
stand in a queue at the ticket window
for hours to book the tickets
many times people would return home
disappointed
after seeing a board of housefull
just imagine traveling all the way to
the theatres
only to come back with no tickets
and what about the reviews back then the
only way to know about it
was by asking their friends one by one
in short watching a movie was a big
project in those days
so how did book my show crack this code
for us
the story starts in south africa
three friends from india who were
vacationing together
noticed that south africans purchased
their rugby tickets
through the radio people could call into
the radio station
and buy the tickets from them sure
it wasn't a perfect solution but it was
way better than standing in line for
hours
so when three of them came back they
decided to implement a similar ticket
booking system
in india thus they started
victory entertainment where ticket
bookings would happen on a telephone
they would buy tickets in bulk from the
movie theaters
and the customers could call big tree
and reserve their tickets
the delivery boys would then deliver the
tickets at their homes
and collect payments it was a lot of
work for big tree
but the customers loved it nobody had to
spend
extra time getting the ticket and
everyone had an assured ticket delivered
at their doorstep
in this way they quickly addressed the
customer's core problems
by giving them the reliability of
confirmation of tickets
and the convenience of home delivery
thus keeping users problems at the
center of building a solution
was the trick and it worked
all was going great investors gave them
money
they hired employees created software to
book online tickets
and earned huge profits until the
competition rose
and other players started a similar
ticket booking model
now the direct competition was not the
real problem here
but it was the lack of commitment on
their competitors part
that hurt dearly many of the competitors
were unable to fulfill the promises
given to their customers
this caused a bad reputation to all the
other players
just the way a few mischievous students
cause your entire class to be termed as
notorious
or indisciplined unfortunately
bookmyshow also had to pay a price for
someone else's faults
within a few years bookmyshow lost most
of its funds
it was reduced to a six-member team from
they could no longer afford to buy
tickets in bulk or pay to their delivery
boys
things were looking bleak for book my
show
but they just didn't lose hope with a
determination to
rise from this tight spot they started
looking for new solutions
and this time they identified the
problem at the other end
the multiplexes with an increasing
number of multiplexes
many were struggling with hiring ticket
booking associates
seating helpers cash counter managers
and
day-to-day theater managers big headache
right
and this was the moment when book my
show seized the opportunity
and saved the day they came up with the
software for multiplexes as well
that took care of all these problems
this
was a game changer riding on its success
they forayed into other categories for
ticketing like sports
events dramas ipl music concerts
festivals flea markets and so on
in this way they not only could rise
again to newer heights
but their ideas revolutionized the
ticketing experience
for all of us so the next time when you
book a movie ticket on a click
remember book my show's ticket to
success
the bms story not only teaches us how to
build user-centric ventures
but it also shows us how to embrace
failure
and turn adversity to opportunity so
did you find the bms story interesting
do let us know your thoughts and don't
forget to visit the endpower website
to learn more about entrepreneurship
happy learning